[Music]
what tonight we're going to cover chest
tactics the bishop and queen attacking
the King work six king auryx seven
squares it's a continuation of blacks
last week's class we only got through
half of the examples so this is our
first position it's quite apparent that
white is going to be doing the attacking
in as much as blacks bishop a shed in
behind the pawns looks like it was a
French defense now White's Bishop isn't
ready to do the attack it's only on f1
and the the white knight on f3 is ready
to move up to g5 to join the attack and
the Queen can go maybe to c2 or or go on
up to h5 to help out so let's see what
the first move is okay so the bishop
comes out it's now aiming toward the
king side and threatens to win a pawn by
Bishop takes Knight pawn takes Bishop
and rook takes pawn on d5 so let's see
what black does black retreats the
knight that might be a bad idea
generally when you're in a defensive
position you shouldn't retreat your
forces unless you're forced to so let's
go back the other drawback in blacks
position is obviously his queen knight
on c6 is pinned by the right by the rook
so that brings to mind moving the Queen
out of the way somewhere to break the
pin now we might lose the d5 pawn like I
said Bishop takes Knight pawn takes but
let's say our queen had moved to b6 we
could move the the white score bishop
and attack the right
on d5 and get some counter play for our
pawn along that open diagonal so anyway
I think Knight to e7 is a is not the
best move Oh
white goes to the head and sacrifices
right away now we have the Queen and
Knight coming into attack so obviously
the King can't retreat to g8 because
there's no answer to Queen to h5
threatening checkmate that there's no
Knight that can cover the h7 Square and
there's not time to move any of the
pawns up so the King has to advance to
g6 now typically with this the attacking
move for white is to bring the Queen
behind the knight to get a discovered
check on the King which by the way might
win the black queen Knight takes King
pawn check
Knight takes Queen now our queen would
be hanging to the black bishop but after
we take the Queen we can snap off the
rook on a eight and probably have more
than enough compensation we'd get two
pawns in a rook for the two pieces so
let's see so white does bring the Queen
up now we know what the threat is
White's threatening more or less Knight
takes c6 check but there's also the
possible threat of pawn on h2 can join
the attack with H 2 to H 4 which would
threaten H 5 check and that would also
allow the work to come into the attack
through work to h3 and rook to g3 so
let's see what black tries to do okay
this is the typical defense for black in
this scenario where the Queen threatens
the discovered attack you attack the
Queen
now to keep the attack going white has
the choice he could retreat Queen the g3
which would wreath retin-a discover
check and he would also have to weigh
pawn takes pawn and pissants
on f6 as to which would give the
stronger attack
now if pawn takes pawn black would like
to take with the King to get out of that
discovered check rook takes wouldn't get
out of this cover check so let's say
King takes now white Couto 97 forking
the work and King driving the King back
to f7 and we could take the rook and we
would get compensation for our two
pieces so we'd have a pawn and I work
six points and he would have two pieces
so that would probably be justify our
sacrifice but let's see what white comes
up with I I don't remember okay
rather than pawn takes pawn and pass on
even though black white would win the
rook in and the pawn for the two pieces
white chose to bring the Queen back to
continue attacking because white felt
that after he would take the rook and
without the minor pieces and he wouldn't
have the Queen thread anymore that black
would have an equal game and whites
attack would fizzle out so that's why
white chose to retreat the Queen
renewing the threat of Knight takes c6
and it's the bigger threat now because
it would win the Queen out right so
black has to move the Queen notice he he
can't move the King back he could move
it to the side of the board with Queen
King to h6
that probably wouldn't help black
because white could protect the night
will say with Bishop back to c1 and that
would threaten discover check what the
King at age six wouldn't it Knight takes
pawn and on top of that white would also
threaten Queen h4 check and the King
goes back to g6 the answer would be
Queen to h7 checkmate so moving the King
to h6 isn't really an option either so
he moves the Queen so it's out of the
way of the night so he drops it back to
c8 he he knows he has to put he wants to
stay on the bishop he wants to protect
that east six square reinforce the
protection that's why he chose c8 and he
wanted to get away from the knight if he
went to d8 that he would still the
knight could still hit him and going to
be eight wouldn't make any sense because
the Queen can't do anything from b8 at
least it's c8 it protects the bishop all
right let's see what white is going to
do I have a suspicion it's age four
let's see
nope okay now he drops his rook back
that's interesting he's going to
redeploy his rook along the third-ranked
maybe he's going to move his queen maybe
to f4 and then bring the work to g3 and
have a discovered check with the rook
also interesting Oh
again though Black Knights pinned
against the Queen so the Black Knight
can't take that d4 pawn which is no
longer protected by the bishop because
the work blocks the bishop
anyway blacks problem is even though
he's a piece up he doesn't have any good
squares for his pieces and white can
always win a pawn and the rook with
Knight takes pawn on e6 followed by
Knight takes rook let's see what okay he
tries f4 he's going to try to drive the
Queen away and he opens up a nice square
for his Knight if he gets the chance he
can drop that Knight from East 7f 5 and
maybe that would help defend the King so
the Queen just goes up renewing the
discovered check but notice that now the
rook the white work can come to h3 and
then the threat would be Queen to h5
check and the king would have to go up
to f5 and we would have a discovered
check and it would soon be checkmate so
let's see what plant comes up with black
drops his knight in to f5 and white
swings has Rick over to h3 threatening
the Queen h5 check so now it looks like
blacks gonna have to swing is Rick from
f8 to h8 to guard of the Queen to h5
threatened check now that's going to
pose the other problems if he does that
it looks like white can do something
like Knight takes c6 pawn discovered
check notice that the white knight in
the white queen note well they're
attacking the g7 pawn but it is
protected by the knight on f5 so I'm not
sure let's see what happens so the work
does come over that prevents Queen h5
check now our problem is what is the
correct attacking maneuver for a white
here
I think we're at a critical point where
white may have a win who sees the win
let's see nope so much for that
Knight to e6 King to f7 oh look we
forgot that after taking the pawn on e6
the Knights unprotected so Queen takes
Knight and this is an obvious win King
over here now he's threatening to take
our knight of course we have a nice
check on g5 if we need it so let's say
we do Queen the g5 check what would
black do King takes Knights then what do
we do as white after King takes Knight
on g6 right that forces him back to e7
doesn't it then we got Queen takes g7
pawn check and now we're on the Rick
with the Queen and he can't defer let's
see and he can't move the king up when
we check him on g7 he can't go to d6
because our pawn covers that square that
means he's forced to the first row and
we would have worked a trick check
winning the Queen so I think we just
solved it yep yep there we go nice win
very good let's go on to our next
example this is easy Black is
threatening Queen takes rook pawn Czech
followed by Queen to a-1 checkmate so
whatever we do it has to be fast white
to play and win what's the winning move
for white right and our Bishop covers
the two escaped squares setting up the
checkmate which follows Rick over
checkmate that's pretty and of course we
knew it had to be checkmate because
black was threatening to checkmate us in
turn so we it had to all be forced
checks okay this is kind of like the
last one the black kings in the corner
the white bishop on b3 keeps the king in
the corner we have a knight on
h5 with at some point Knight to g6 check
we have a rook on f3 waiting to finish
off the attack so this is pretty easy
what's the winning move for white
right Knight to g6 pawn takes rook to f3
threatening work over mate and pawn up
doesn't work and the King move doesn't
work so there's no silk no answer for
black that's a nice nice checkmate there
okay on the other hand white has some
attacking chances himself he has the
Queen on c2 attacking h7 his knight is
hovering around the black king and his
rook is conveniently placed on f3 where
it can go to h3 in attack with the with
the Queen so it must be white to play
and win you got it what is it okay King
takes rook over King back now the pawns
pinned and they can't staff right 88
very good nose that's pretty this is
even easier Mike would you care to do
the honors since you're solving all
these for us okay
ting over King up check me very good
I think we're getting that pattern down
I can't wait to play it in my next game
the black queen is pinned to the king
that looks desperate but black wins just
like the last checkmate so black to play
and win I'm not even going to ask Mike
to bother telling us what it is 90 to
check rook takes pawn Shaq and Rick over
oh the Queen comes in and then we have
the checkmate okay well after four or
five in a row it does help maybe the
next one will be more complicated wait
to play and win I'm open to suggestions
okay well let's let's see what the
author has to say f5 o pawn takes well
this is easy now what we'll run through
this and then we'll go back so now it
works like a champ
there's our checkmate all right let's
see
well white obviously is the attacker
white has three minor pieces up black
only has two white has a nice center
pawn shoved up on black so black can't
get his white square bishop develops and
blacks Kings in the center sometimes the
author we have to develop these things a
little bit though so let's see what
happens
okay the knight comes in so the answer
is going to be Castle and this is easy
now we play queen up pawn up now the F
pawns pin so the Knights not really
protected
Queen takes Knight pawn takes Bishop
takes Queen over oh and then just drop
the bishop in because the both the King
side pawns are pin that's kind of pretty
and there's no way to stop the checkmate
okay see what our next one is okay I
just gave it away Knight takes pawn
I guess Queen over well we're gonna
obviously Knight takes pawn check wipes
out blacks King side and it's a double
check so the King would have to move
over okay so I propose Knight takes h6
check anyone see a better move than that
all right Knight so the King has to go
there now what's the what's the how to
fit how does white finish black off who
would suggest a move go back right right
and then the mate very good okay well I
have more time than examples but very
good thanks that'll do it for tonight
[Music]